first ones easy second one uses it so
it's a little more complex correct
what did you select as your you'd and
your DV that was you so you will often
select X as you when you can because
when you go to the right hand side over
here do your DX it just becomes it just
becomes 1 so this is gonna be really
good for you when you're doing the
intubation later on okay so that makes
DV on DX yes see you got a double bonus
here right cuz you got something that
was easy to differentiate and you got
something that was easy to integrate
that's nice so you have this okay so now
let's put it together shall we the first
part is UV you just read down this
column now we do this piece over here
right we're subtracting the integral of
V du U which is just the X isn't it this
is super super easy right in fact mm-hmm
I'm pretty sure you've seen this exact
question before in 3 inner papers right
because they'll say differentiate X e to
the X and hence integrated XE v DX
because just falls out okay
moving over let's see via do with that
the grid so you can start to see it what
did you select as u x squared okay
so therefore do you on the X to X so now
you want DB on the X so you can see I
sort of go around in a circle right
that's the the person give me an X to
draw the function
when I'm writing you might like to UM
write this is capital by 4 integral
doesn't make that much of a difference
for these questions but in a couple of
examples I'm going to show you if it
does make a difference capital I so
what's it equal to what do we start with
you read down the left-hand column okay
now what are we subtracting I'm going to
subtract VDU right now on the face of
this this this looks bad okay all right
we just worked out what this is
well it's this is double what I want
right so this is x squared e to the X
minus 2 of these guys right okay there
you go happy with that okay now